it is time bring out your pocketbooks
open up that purse show me those dollar
dollar bills y'all
and your stupid if you're betting money
on this game with an old blog ball that
bounces a lot of different ways for real
though I listen to what we say how are
you feeling about your pics I feel
pretty good I feel pretty good you had a
lot of prep time today I did I feel
better this week than I do last week
last week I was just you know there was
too many games that I kind of liked but
there was like one thing that scared me
okay I feel like I have like a few games
this week I feel pretty good I made all
of my picks last night which it's
probably not good because I feel like
the pics I make during the day are
usually my 4 o'clock Sunday night and
those are the ones I normally win gotcha
I picked a lot of upsets did you I did
just a little preview yeah before we go
forward yeah I must look at how we got
here
Oh Josh all right gentlemen here's how
last week looked last week Sims you went
nine and seven bringing you two on the
season 95 92 and four left go 95 and
four ninety five ninety two and four
okay good left go last week you went six
and ten bringing it to you okay on the
season 90 to 95 and four so the same
record no you at he's 95 92 and for your
flip records don't matter though what's
the money looking at the money last week
Sims you made $200 left go you lost $200
Oh meeting on the season Sims you are at
negative 240 and left go you are at plus
260 which means I'm up 500 bucks all
right you've gained $400 on me from last
week yeah
what really sucks if the Steelers could
have just held on to that frickin game I
really would have been fine yeah yeah
yeah
all right so about 500 the week before I
was up 900 so you're eating into me and
we're I just would get this on the
record now we're including playoffs
including playoffs yeah okay I'm just
I'm just we do this every year and make
sure
all right you guys ready get started
here hey I'm hold how did he doing
guaranteed to lose guaranteed Toulouse
Sims went for and won Oh Thank You chase
Daniel's you've [ __ ] backup
quarterback you fifty and fifteen on the
season and left what is that like a
winning percentage I don't know I'll
look it up good and then let go you went
three and one and left goes lock so
you're 23 26 and for chase Daniel
screwed you as well he did so here
here's what's interesting about left
collogues if I go for Ando which is a
very tall task by Jeff I will be over
500 and left ko locks for the first time
all season if I go three and one right
I'll be 26 27 and 4 if I can be over 500
for the year yeah I am going to be
ruthless on instagram ruthless so root
for me to see me in the comment section
all right guys first game of the week
here Thursday Night Football we
previewed this on yesterday's podcast
Jacksonville at Tennessee spread in this
game is Titans - four and a half whether
tonight in Nashville is cloudy low of 36
say I'm excited to watch this game I am
excited okay I am back to you yep yeah I
only question I mean it doesn't take a
whole lot for me to get excited to watch
a football game I mean we have one team
fighting for a playoff spot another team
that's just got a bunch of like badass
mofos who are psychos so I kind of like
that too and that's the Jacksonville
Jaguars so I guess that's what excites
me they're more than anything the Jags
got four net back that of course is a
big advantage I don't know what to think
about you know the matchup of the Jags
defense versus the Titans offense I
guess that's where to go who the hell
are the Titans offense I don't know I
don't know I mean it's just it's all
over the place you know so from that
from that standpoint I mean can the
Titans run the ball on the Jags I mean
that's the one little weakness with the
Jags D I don't really think so the
Titans haven't shown the ability to run
the ball on anybody really so you know
from there I go uh and then the other
side of the ball from there I go oh yeah
and then then I go the other side of the
ball Jaguars okay they can run the ball
if there's a weakness of the Titans
defense is the
they're run defense to to a degree as
well but I don't know if the Jags can
throw the ball well enough to back the
Titans off of the running game so I
guess that's where I question this it's
a Thursday Night Football game common
opponent I'm going $10 okay ten I don't
even like to do these that's you
but $10 on the Jacksonville Jaguars I
think it's going to be a 16-13 Titans
win I didn't understand your doing are
you picking the Jags I don't know I do
it after I make my but I just wanted you
to talk to your jacket one more time
yeah talk about how I thanked
quarterback so that you could look at
the screen and go but that was good I
was really good at your new one good at
your best one of the year
Raymond this year you're a Jag you're
moving in your spirit animal yeah is it
over
but you breathed some saliva right is
that what happened oh yeah okay hey your
clean shave today I know the real
problem is you I'm gonna say something
that's gonna get me made fun of I am a
mess right now
I thought I brought my laundry down and
I threw my trash out in the dumpster
okay
and I'm sitting there and I walked two
blocks to the train and I'm waiting for
the train and I go holy crap I forgot my
laundry all of my laundry all of my
underwear socks everything by the
freaking dumpster I sprint two blocks
back I think I leaped over a baby
carriage I don't know probably not
contain count that I get there no
clothes I live in a fifth floor walk-up
i sprint up the five floors space tell
me I was there it's there for the last
three hours yeah I have been coughing
and breathing heavy I'm officially out
of shame because I sprinted two blocks
and then ran up five flights yes and
that was a combination with that right
well at least so what do you have to do
even three
your laundry to the laundromat yeah I
give it to Chun and Chun does it and so
Chun is actually the guy's name right
and I've become friends with him but I
have the worst handshakes with him every
time right to the point where today I
came in like this and I was gonna just
end it and then he went this and was
like and I was like Chun we've never
snapped you can just grab his wrist like
I do to the random white people in this
office like I do it Josh when I've had
to do this and he got come on Josh go
flat boom you're weird that no one else
goes flat for some reason the titans
under the jacks are the titans on the
jaguars yeah last six games titans are
five and one straight up and against the
spread they were a 10-point underdog
earlier this season they ended up
winning by three I looked at at how they
ran the ball last time and you know what
the big thing was Titans had 150 rushing
yards against the Jaguars last time yeah
because Mariota had 51 right there's
something about Mariota
he watches the film and goes I need to
run if we're gonna beat the jaguars
because he did it last year both games
yet he it's just it's the one game he
decides to run every year also
interesting little note yeah kind of
curious that Dion Lewis called out the
Patriots and then it hasn't done
anything since the Patriots game like
that to change I believe that the issue
is not the Titans the issue is that
Jaguars offense I think that Jaguars win
this game 16 to 9 what did you have
sixteen thirteen sixty you're going on
the Jags I'm going with the Titans oh
the tights you said the Jags
oh my bad 16 9 times cos that's a cover
there is no reason to watch Thursday
Night Football
I have blast Marcus Mariota with the
gift of running and today you shall see
him eclipsed 7d rushing yards Julian
chillin Ramses custom Julian okay I'm
only putting $50 Tennessee I don't want
anything to do with this game but I
thought we had established that $10 is
for wimps yeah so anyway alright guys
might want it e I didn't want to get
away from my $50 $10 went that but man I
had two bets that I liked and I just
find some extra chump change alright
guys moving on to the Sunday slate here
first game at one o'clock the New York
Jets visiting the Buffalo Bill spread in
this game is Buffalo minus three weather
in Buffalo on Sunday partly cloudy high
of 31 Christmas ooh high of 31 okay so
and same darn oh there's a thousand
percent play ok you texted them you
called them stage stage five dollar solo
yeah honestly I don't even know to text
them okay because I always want to text
them yeah and then I'm like all I want
to talk about is football
yeah I don't want to be like hey geez
you have shown up flicks like I don't
know what to text him anymore
yeah so I just don't text anymore okay
what do you text people hey man hope
you're great yeah and then what happens
when they go yeah then you go okay end
of conversation or I just get into it I
don't know I mean screw say and Arnold
Texas on sale
I don't text anybody yeah so like I'm
not good at like I don't text my friends
my friends like your bad text was like I
know yeah well it's hard in our life we
have a lot of people texting us and
eating us anyways and I get home at the
end of the day sometimes I don't want
yeah but balls and I might do dead I've
talked for like five hours straight
today I just can't [ __ ] look would
you go with rooms walked out I wanna
bills
alright jets are bills here we go bills
okay look here Josh Allen's been amazing
the last two weeks
his running the football is a difference
and for any team for any game that they
play in I mean he's dangerous to so
dangerous to the point where there's no
doubt they will have a spy like Jamal
Adams on Josh Allen this week let me
just tell you this he ran from 9 for 135
last week and Kiko Alonso spied on many
of those times and he ran right by Kiko
for big gains so that's how gifted this
guy is also the Bills have found a
little bit of a passing game it's not
beautiful but some of these young guys
the isaiah mckenzie and the robert
thomas they have comfortable enough to
release kelvin bench exactly right and
andre Holmes right I mean come on
Benjamin hasn't been open and let me
check my watch oh it's been four years
how bad was he in that Miami game he's
horrible like he had a few drops that
were like that's the only thing you can
do and he doesn't and then he did a
you're right I mean it's just
and then the the effort that he shows
the body language you're doing
interception where one time it was it
wasn't the greatest decision but
Benjamin did nothing to help out the
interception and then didn't chase the
guy as he intercepted the ball was
running away he just sad stood there
watch I would guarantee it's those
little things that McDermott saw on
Monday and was like [ __ ] this guy get
him off our team so but the Titans I
mean that Titans the bills I do think
we'll be able to move the ball a little
bit on the Jets it's not gonna be pretty
I mean I understand that but I do think
the run game has created an up with sean
mccoy and the josh allen factor that you
have to respect it and then you also
have to respect the you know ak-47 on
the right shoulder of josh allen too
that stresses the defense out and then i
just look at the bill I mean the Bills
defense against that Jets Jets offense
and just go I don't see it I don't
understand I mean can the Jets run the
ball in the bills I wouldn't think so I
think that's their only chance if they
wanted to pull this off as they have to
have a dominant run game performance
I say no so I'm going $50 on the Buffalo
Bills I am going to pick them to win the
game 17 to 12 yeah I mean the bills two
of the last three games they've had over
200 yards rushing I also look at the
bills at home
they beat the Jaguars at home they had a
really good three quarters against the
Patriots at home they beat the Titans at
home and the game against the Bears was
the Nathan Peterman it's time to retire
game right I am putting a hundred and
fifty dollars on the bills and I have
them winning 24 to 16 so I have them
winning by eight it's for 16 its I know
I feel bad for my friends say I'm darn
old having to go up against Sean
McDermott it was time to come back your
first week back to and you're going up
to cold Buffalo and there's not a
receiver on on the Jets that are gonna
scare Buffalo yeah and I don't think
their offensive lines that could right
and I think that Josh Allen is able to
create more magic than Sammis and so
three points was not enough for me I
mean this is a team that beat the
Buffalo that beat the Jets 41 to 9 and
their quarterback
Matt Barkley yeah and now they get to
play at home right I just I don't see it
for the Jets I'm with you I haven't
really seen them been being a game in
the last few weeks well they were
leading most of last week true I know
that was the other thing that I thought
about was I mean the deflation after
that guys exactly right I mean if you
want a team come back and destroy right
where you controlled the game for three
quarters basically yeah like it's over
yeah I I think so yeah
all right guys next game on Sunday the
New York Giants on the road visiting
Washington spread in this game Giants
are favored by three and a half whether
in Maryland on Sunday and feel like
matching up my scores with the bets on
the side mostly cloudy with a high of 34
what do you mean I didn't feel like
bashing it up well we're doing the
Giants Washington game look at the score
next to the game down there I guess it's
the old scores from last week my bad
no it's not the old scores from last
week it's just you put it in the exact
order I sent the email in oh you didn't
send it in the order of the spreadsheet
that's on you know because you looked at
I can't I can't look at Burger you look
at my first email I sent you three I
it's unbelievable he sends it to me in
pieces he sends me the scores first guys
I don't send the money okay go ahead
Giants Giants visiting Washington very
cute relationship just send it to me all
once that'll solve this is how you would
be as a GM in the NFL yeah of course
damn hold people accountable [ __ ] a
[ __ ] guy can't read and write at the
same time okay Redskins Giants come on
what do we think the Redskins offense is
gonna do I don't know I don't know I
mean I really don't I don't know what to
expect for the Redskins it's very dicey
and scary to me creature and Peterson's
getting slow and Mark Sanchez you're
right I mean it's just hard to imagine
the Redskins creating a whole lot of
offense against the Giants defense
that's pretty stout up front I don't
think they're gonna be able to have
their way in the run game and rely on AP
and the run game just to dominate the
Giants so I don't see that happening and
of course I've never thought their pass
game was explosive enough to do anything
like that either now I don't look at the
other side of the ball as being a
favorable matchup for the New York
Giants but the Giants have two things
going for them a little bit they
have found a running game the right side
of their offensive line has been better
so it gives them a fighting chance they
have been protecting enough to where Eli
has moments of having people open and
maybe he can throw the ball down the
field so for all of those reasons and
just the fact that the Giants have a few
playmakers and difference-makers on the
field I'm picky I'm going with the
Giants $100 and I'm picking the Giants
to win let's go John it's 21 to 13 over
the Washington team I'm gonna stop
saying that word what made you say that
I don't know I just can't take it
anymore is it because I've influenced
you good what are they gonna do about
Reubens Fosters what I want to know you
heard about his girlfriend on Good
Morning America I did not watch it I did
not read it so today I know that she
went on she went on and said that when
she lied about recanting her charge at
San Francisco that she just loved him
and he did beat her then and that all
happened but she still loved them and
didn't want to ruin his career so she
told the police and everybody that she
lied right and then she told the story
about how she was in the hotel this time
he slapped the phone out of her hand and
she also says that the 49ers came up and
got involved in the police investigation
right and basically tried to badger her
I'm very interested to know what story
Bruce Allen heard that none of us heard
because that's what he said right right
right he said he said I know some things
that aren't out there yet right I
believe you should have to share those
things right because I think this is
pretty clear okay but and then also you
can't be upset about the media coverage
because you decided to do that exactly
ah Giants at Washington exactly how I
thought I'm seeing Adrian Peterson slow
down the offensive line is and the
strong as it once was the defense we got
to be honest the minovsky defense is
starting to kind of get tired it's
starting to collapse a little bit I'm
not seeing them pressure the quarterback
as much I'm not seeing him play that
great and also their secondary isn't
that really that good I'm only going $50
though right the half point scares me
and it's not about I have no faith in
Washington but the Giants are also a
team that I don't have that much faith
in either right
and so of course they have Odell and of
course they have the sake one I also
think there's part of the Giants where I
look at their team and I look at their
schedule again if you listen to us
before the year we a hundred percent
predicted this we predicted they would
start off one in six and then come
roaring back at the end of the year but
the one thing I will say is they've gone
three and a three out of the last four
is they've played Nick Mullens they've
played chase Daniel now they're playing
Mark Sanchez so this is what I want
everyone to know we're in week 14 when
they bring Eli Manning back next year
and they talk about how they finish the
year going five and three or something
like that remember that they play backup
quarterbacks and that Eli Manning
actually didn't really do anything and
the best throw the whole end of the year
was Odell Beckham I'm going $50 on the
New York Giants to cover the three and a
half $50 all right guys next game on
Sunday at 1 o'clock the New Orleans
Saints on the road visiting the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers spread in this game
Saints minus 8 thunderstorms in the
forecast vampa 87% humidity 100 percent
chance of precipitation high of 74 that
sounds like a scary weather report for a
dome team Chris yeah it definitely it's
actually a scary weather report for both
teams really I mean actually yeah and I
didn't even think of this is this
totally just off the time I actually
think it might favor the Saints Oh
commuters are running they can run the
ball exactly right that's that's where I
go oh they want the weather a messy
sloppy physical run game favors the
Saints than that so but either way if we
get into this we talk about the
Buccaneers offense you know their run
game is spotty it's just good enough to
where you can't totally disrespect it
all the time I don't expect them to be
able to run against the Saints I do
expect them to have some plays and make
some plays in the pass game and the
Bucks have shown that you know again
that they can protect at times too and
give Jameis Winston and company the
opportunities to throw the ball down the
field
so I see the Bucs moving the ball a
little bit on this Saints team
the Saints though with the extra time
you know coming off a loss in which they
did where they were physically dominated
you know I look at their offense of
course and just go how do they not have
their way with the Bucks and a lot of
different areas I would think they can
run the ball on the Bucks of course I
think they can pass the ball as well you
know the Bucks of course have some guys
I can come off the edge and get after
the passer a little bit but the Saints
are a very good pass protecting team
this Bucks defense is not the Cowboys
defense by any stretch of the
imagination I still think the the New
Orleans Saints are of course a very very
good football team but something just
scares me a little bit about being down
in Tampa Bay okay I am going $50 on the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers I fully expect the
Saints to win the game wasn't sure if
there was one more in there
I think there's six cannons on that ship
I think you're two bullets short there
this Saints 31 to 24 so Tampa Bay four
of their five wins are at home they're
four and two they played different at
home we saw last week against Carolina
yeah drew Brees in Tampa Bay right
overall he's played there 12 times what
do you think his record is I looked up
all these numbers this is for the next
few games I looked up quarterback plays
at Division rivals hmm I'm gonna say
he's 12 times yeah I'm gonna say 7 and 5
you nailed it in his last five games
Tampa Bay he's lost two right and the
three games he's won he's won by two
points right three points and seven
points he's lost two in a row there
he's touchdown to interception ratio in
Tampa the last five games five
touchdowns nine interceptions he's been
sacked 11 times and now you're telling
me it's gonna be messy I don't see the
Saints losing this game mainly because
of what just happened to Dallas but I
have them winning 31 to 28 and I am
putting a hundred and fifty dollars on
Tampa plus eight
yo yo yo that pirate's life for me I I
just look at it and I go this is a Tampa
team at home we just saw what happened
with Carolina yeah Tim Pat Holmes all I
always say it's like Buffalo home or
Chicago at home it's just a weird place
yeah I just think I don't know man the
scenes do not play well there we're
gonna get to the very next game it's
very similar to this yeah weekend at
Miami right but I just I really like I'm
tempted to make Tampa Bay plus a to lock
it's a lot of points it is a lot of
points thank you for your insight well I
just what I'm just I'm done betting on
teams that are just inconsistent that's
one of the things I focused on this week
that come done with that [ __ ] I'm done I
don't know a game could be 3128 it could
be 31 to 10 I don't know where the
[ __ ] could be that's where I would
just say buyer beware do you okay have
any of the four games thus far felt lock
worthy do lock probably not no not yet
all right guys next game at 1:00 o'clock
the New England Patriots on the road
visiting the Miami Dolphins spread in
this game New England minus seven and a
half whether in Miami on Sunday
scattered thunderstorms high of 81 78%
humidity ooh hot one human humid one a
little detox session in that game
help what was the humidity seven 78% and
what was the temperature 81 high 50%
chance of precipitation 50% chance of
precipitation winds out of the Southwest
17 miles an hour mm damn not the
southwest winds that's off the gulf side
so that could be sunset at 5:30 so game
should be completely good not prime
salty wind all right so okay I think if
I had to start there I'd start with the
Dolphins offense I'm not very impressed
with the Dolphins offense and I am
impressed with the Patriots defense
malke gods like Malcolm Brown and
Lawrence guy in the middle have been
kicking ass for that team linebackers
are healthy the venmo is the Atlanta and
Roberts Addante high towers are really
good the secondary is really peaking
into form you know I like the JC Jackson
and Stephon Gilmore combo at corner on
the outside with the McCourty twins
locking down safety Nichols
situations and then they got my man Obi
and Darren Harmon and Patrick Chung all
in the safety mix but it's the big guys
up front that have really impressed me I
just look at the Dolphins offense you
know with some of the injuries they've
had at receiver I just go okay I don't
expect them to be able to run the ball
on the New England Patriots I think
their pass game is a little bit
predictable for the New England Patriots
and I don't think the personnel is going
to scare the New England Patriots now on
the other side of the ball I'm very
scared for the Miami Dolphins defense
and I'm with you I mean I know it's
scary going down into Miami and having
to deal with that New England certainly
hasn't had a great history there the
Dolphins
their bright spot yeah some decent pass
rushers and my man 25 Xavier who is like
is out is he out for sure I'm almost
positive how do you % you like he's week
to week yeah and in my opinion yeah week
to win your week to week and it's the
first week that your week to week you're
likely not playing right and if you are
playing it's a Saturday decision week
where you're barely your week if you're
out if you're not out that week you're
weak yeah that's a good way to put it
when you're standing when you're waiting
the week you're weak you tell me if you
play on that first week yeah right yet
so okay don't wet your beak with all
that week it's a dolphin um but I don't
even know what I'm talking about now
either way this is where I wanted to get
to okay the Patriots and they're their
team and what they do on the offensive
side of the ball right now it is not
about Tom Brady throwing for 300 yards
anymore again we got to get it it's
about power I form whoop your ass
football that's what they want to do and
you know who's horrible at defending
that man the Miami Dolphins can't stop
anything in the run game I don't know
where they are they're letting up 144
yards in the running game per game and
they're only the bangles are worse than
that at just a real quick look I think
there's so there's second to last right
that is very scary against these oline
the Patriots the amazing play-action
passing game they have now we know
xavius our is that doubtful or whatever
who gives a damn they're gonna have it
for hard time so because of that I'm
going 360 dollars
ha ha
it's the revolution in Maya me we're
coming down there to shape the ghost we
got a whoop your ass the most we are the
Patriots were rounding into form it's
December this is what we do to do to do
do I like that song yeah everyone gets
me juice to classic it is a classic I
hoped amigos remix it and I'm picking uh
Josh mess I know I'm getting in my score
34 to 20 mmm going with the Patriots
they're okay they're Jaguar I'm not
Jaguars got a little so this isn't his
throat this is another matchup that's
very odd with why this team yeah should
be kicking this team's ass and they
don't I know in the last five years in
Miami yeah Patriots are one in four
straight up and against the spread he's
seven and nine career there I think he
is seven and nine yeah and he he's one
in four in the last five the Dolphins
are five and one against the spread at
home this season again some of them
we've discussed have been lucky yeah
Tannehill is 3 & 1 against the Patriots
at home his touchdown interception ratio
in those four games is 7 to 1 mhm and
two of his four game or at Suze two of
his three games have gone over 300 yards
passing yep Tom Brady and Miami like he
sometimes plays well they don't yeah but
in my analysis yeah I don't think the
Dolphins can stop the Patriots running
attack because I think typically like I
think about last year's game it was Tom
Brady trying to drop back and it was the
first time that we looked at Amendola
and Edelman and we thought if they don't
have Grunk yeah
they don't have guys that can win
one-on-one matchups right and I look at
this team now and it's a completely
different organization exactly right
Josh Gordon can win on one amount
matchups cordarrelle Patterson I mean
the fact that he did against Minnesota
was awesome yeah Gronk is getting
healthy now Sonne Michelle James white
it's a different Patriots seeing that
we've seen and in those seven wins this
is what I found interesting the reason I
was comfortable with the Bucks is that
in the Saints close
wins it was in the seats wins it was two
three and seven in the Patriots seven
wins the average margin of victory has
been by 13 points so when they lose you
know it's not clicking but when they win
they win big this feels like a win big
I'm going Patriots 3217 and I have $100
on the Patriots to cover the Sprint's
they're out of the way Manhattan the
Manhattan I don't think Manhattan is
just another name for minestrone it's
like the same so Manhattan's the red
blood but I would always go New England
you would that's the white their kids do
the New England okay do you even eat
soup now clam chowder get the hell out
of here with that
what about lobster bisque maybe I would
do that I eat soup every what's every
night for dinner so maybe like chicken
Newton Yeah right or lentil or
minestrone minestrone minestrone
minestrone minestrone you sure yeah
because I used to say minestrone and
then you sure it's not just like cheesy
northeast centers or try to act like
they're over Italian like it like hey
you Gobots say what some would you want
some boats it's minestrone next game and
what o'clock on Sunday the Baltimore a
really visiting the Kansas City Chiefs
hold on you were putting 360 and you
didn't go what if this is one of those
weird Miami games I didn't scare you at
all I mean it scares me it's the only
thing that scared me I was as I was
thinking about this game I was thinking
about you throwing all these stats at me
and I understand their history there I
didn't know all the numbers you said and
I was just going like Chris just it's
it's this year just it's this team and I
just try just block my mind out of that
so we thought they were gonna kill him
last year if I'm wrong I'm wrong but I
feel I feel different this year because
it's the run game and not having to
depend on the pass that's why I felt all
right guys next game I want o'clock on
Sunday Baltimore at Kansas City spread
in this game is Chiefs minus six and a
half whether in Kansas City on Sunday
high of 38 mostly sunny Chris okay I
mean this is the left go Sims game of
the week right it is I mean there's no
ice no game I cannot wait to watch on
Sunday
I really I'm too many games to watch on
Sunday holy crap I don't even know how
to figure out which team it's gonna be
tough it really is I mean there's five
ago at five games at four o'clock I mean
that's like should be against the rules
okay so where do we start with this
matchup okay I mean I think we do this
we go Baltimore's offense versus the
Chiefs defense I you know I expect
Baltimore to be able to bludgeon the
Chiefs to a degree in the run game I do
you know not that it's always gonna be
just straight downhill right between the
tackles but you know Lamar around the
edge we'll see if Kenneth Dixon
continues to get a little more involved
here all of that but I do think at the
end of the day they're gonna be able to
move the pile forward a whole lot in the
run game I just still don't know if the
Kansas City run defense has the right
fits I don't know if they got enough big
guys really other than Chris Jones where
I go in this type of matchup against the
Baltimore Ravens who have an enormous
offensive line that's gonna be tough
it's gonna be tough sledding for guys
like D Ford and dealing with this run
game in this type of game at 245 pounds
and outside linebacker / defense and you
know middle linebacker play for the
Kansas City Chiefs is nothing special
you know the safety in the box play is
nothing special to stop the run game and
then we know the Ravens pass game is not
special either but Lamar Jackson has
done well enough and Kansas City's
secondary is bad enough to where I still
go I mean I think he's gonna have a
solid day I'm not expecting 300 yards in
the pass game but I'm expecting like 150
or 160 in the pass game and probably
like 80 rushing for Lamar and then
probably close to a hundred for Gus
Edwards as well and a lot of chewing up
the clock and then I just flip it over
to the other side and I know you know
all my thoughts here but I think
Baltimore's defense this is the best
defense
Patrick mahomes has ever played and I
mean that you know personnel-wise okay
it's not as good as Jacksonville earlier
this year but this is gonna be the most
complex scheme he has seen to this point
you know a little like how we talked in
New England how they caught him off
guard with game plan nuances right and
things they did to slow down that attack
well Baltimore is gonna have that too
and they got a whole
more bad mofos on that side of the ball
too than like a New England or anybody
like that so I look at that as long as
Baltimore can somewhat keep a mill homes
in the pocket and if he does get out of
the pocket he's got to go left if he
goes right get get the highlight show
going because if he keeps going right I
mean you just look through the year you
go through Pachamama highlights when he
goes right 7 Yardley right it's laser
beams everywhere Joe Joe Joe Joe all I
know is when I think of him rolling left
I think I'm throwing left handed and
beating the bronc it is good he's
awesome I mean or going left and
throwing all of his body weight going to
install a brake show I'm just saying
it's less likely that way but I think
with the Ravens they're their secondary
talent they have I think that the Kansas
City Chiefs run game I'm not sure you're
gonna be able to depend on that a whole
lot I'm picking the upset okay I am I'm
going $100 on the Baltimore Ravens and I
think they're gonna win the game 27 to
24 in Kansas City but I'm only going 100
so gambling guy Casey started the year
5a no against the spread they caught
Vegas by surprise
since then yeah they're 1 3 and 1 Vegas
has been making their lines big and they
haven't been able to cover let's talk
about that running attack from Baltimore
their last three games they've run for
267 242 207
that's insane yeah they're tied for
seventh in the NFL right now right so
imagine if Lamar had been their
quarterback all year with Gus Edwards
right Casey allowed a hundred and
seventy-one yards rushing to Oakland
their 22nd 189 and 159 in two games to
Denver their 5th 173 to New England
their 11th a hundred and 78 to San
Francisco their seventh Kansas City can
allow a lot of rushing yards and I'd
also say both Denver games were closer
than they should have been New England
was a loss Oakland was not a cover and
San Francisco was almost not a cover
right when they came back right now
let's talk about mahomes against
defenses
the two best past offenses that mahomes
faced at home Arizona ranked number four
yeah he threw for 249 two touchdowns
they did not cover and that game was
really scary late Wright against
Jacksonville he threw for 313 he had
zero touchdowns and two interceptions
and when you think about that game in my
mind the game is more defined by the
Chris Jones interception return for a
touchdown and the two goal line stands
sounds off the head interceptions I'm
saying that total - goal line stands
were bortles threw a pick and then
completely threw a ball into the dirt
right on the fourth and one right and it
was more of Kareem Hunt I felt like in
that game that it was Patrick mahomes
right it's gonna be a very interesting
test I am very surprised that you have
the Baltimore Ravens winning 27 to 24
because I have the Baltimore Ravens
winning 26 to 24 which is insane and I'd
like to say one message to the people of
new horse know that I picked its
retiring but I am betting I'm betting a
hundred and fifty dollars on the Ravens
plus six and a half and I have them
winning 26 to 24 yeah I don't even know
how our scores get aligned I mean is
there really the thing that we're
betting against is we're betting against
mahomes having a big day in the passing
game and we're we're betting against the
Chiefs being able to stop the Ravens on
the third down like they've been able to
do all year right which they didn't do
well last week against they don't won
right Oakland kept going right but yeah
I think mahomes can have a big day where
he might throw for some yards like a
little bit like Jacksonville do you
think Tyreke hill can get behind this
defense at all it's gonna be very hard
and do you think that Travis Kelce who
matches up on travesty the thing that'll
be certainly one of the matchups that
probably favor favor the Baltimore
Ravens it does why a little bit I mean
Tony Jefferson Eric Weddle yeah what
Sony Jefferson status right now is he
totally good to go work what he didn't
play last week you know
but though Kelsey is so hard in the
middle of the field it's very I don't
think they're gonna try to live in
man-to-man anyways Baltimore that's not
what they want to do they're gonna play
man-to-man and the situations and the
personnel sets they feel comfortable in
and then other than that we're gonna see
creative zones so I do think he could
work the middle of the field I don't
think the middle linebackers of the
Baltimore Ravens are incredibly athletic
like Mosley is very good but I'm not
gonna sit here and go he can cover
Travis Kelce around the field no I don't
think that I think that like they might
get yards but are they gonna be a I
don't think it's gonna be yards four
touchdowns I think use me throwing a 40
yard touchdown pass that's the quickness
so when you're watching the game on
Sunday right if he if Patrick mahomes is
throwing deep balls and they're not
going for touchdowns right every time
that happens bet more on Baltimore I
think so because I don't I haven't if
you're doing in life whether they get in
closer and closer it's gonna be hard to
throw a touchdown pass or score a
touchdown at all against Baltimore they
play smart I think the Holmes has to run
a lot too so he might he certainly might
and he has a little advantage there
because they're not the fastest front
seven as we've talked about it I'm just
happy that my Baltimore team is coming
back to life yeah yeah all right good
I thought my dad had it spot-on with
them a little yesterday when he just
said like Baltimore's playing football
the way John Harbaugh wants them to play
like let's go out there and just fight I
want to fight the head coach you fight
the other team and we'll see if we can
get on the bus and we just kick their
ass and I think that they're feeling
that mojo right now all right guys next
game at one o'clock the Indianapolis
Colts on the road visit another real
Texans spread in this game is Houston
minus five Chris yep okay it is a really
good game Jack Doyle do we know the
status there and I'll look it up yep he
might be out for the year I might be I
got too many people going through my
brain he is out for the year yeah okay
so that's that hurts them a little bit
what did he hurt I kick a man it was a
kidney that's all Eric Ebron all right
well I think I look at it like this the
Colts offense yeah it wasn't great last
week I know that and it doesn't hurt
them not having Jack Doyle out there I
mean their tight end sets are pretty
impressive and what they can do to you
especially with that offensive line I do
think their offensive line can negate
the Houston Texans defensive line to a
degree where there
be times where I do think Andrew Luck is
going to make some plays in the past
game against the Houston Texans defense
you know Houston as you always hear me
say their game plan specific - sometimes
they go a little too aggressive in the
back end and try to take away everything
and you can they can let up a big play
here or there and Andrew Luck is as good
as anybody is sitting in the pocket
waiting for that big play to develop I
guess the thing that I look I look at on
the other side though with deshaun
Watson the Houston Texans offense I
don't have you know I don't look at the
use in sections offense as being a
next-level pass game but they're a big
play pass game and I think they're
especially big play pass games when
they've shown the propensity to be able
to run the ball consistently and I
expect them to be able to run the ball
against the Indianapolis Colts so that's
where I look at that and just go home I
think the Colts are a little bit trouble
in that department which then will
compromise their pass game a little bit
and they just don't have enough good
cover corners for me to like them in
this type of matchup you know so for
that I'm betting $100 on the Houston
Texans yeehaw and and I am picking the
Texas to win 31 to 24 so when these two
teams played their first game it changed
the course of both of their seasons
right
the Texans ended up winning this game
remember went to overtime Frank Reich
decided to go for it on fourth and short
inside his own 50 didn't get it and this
was after Andrew Luck roared back from
being down 28 to 10
here's what happened after that game
that was the first game of the Texans
nine-game winning streak since that win
the Texans haven't lost since that game
that was when the Colts offense came
alive if you remember when it was twenty
eight to ten we were texting each other
going I haven't seen Andrew Luck be able
to do anything all game right clowny had
two SEC's
and I believe one was for a fumble
recovery for a touchdown JJ Watt had two
sacks
the Texans defense came alive in that
game and the Colts offense came alive in
that
game - so I love that they're playing
now because this is two teams that I
believe are genuinely gonna be fighting
in this division for the next five year
right here's the one thing though that I
need to point out about my Texans during
the Texans nine-game winning streak they
have held eight of the nine teams - 23
points or less of the nine teams that
they've beaten they've held six of them
- 17 points or less so they've been
shutting people down but here's the
counterpoint I know you're gonna go with
this here is the points per game here is
the point scored rankings of the teams
they've beaten in the not in eight games
not including the co has employed one
good like twenty four five thirty one
thirty twenty five seventeen twenty
seven twenty eight twenty right they
have not played a team in the top half
of the NFL in scoring offense yeah in
this winning streak right
India's ranked eighth I believe just
like you do that the Texans are gonna
win their 10th game in a row yeah I have
them winning 33 to 30 and I have the
Colts covering the spread and I'm
putting a hundred and fifty on it two
hundred and fifty dollars sweet Oh
Andrew thanks for pulling up on your
steve-o tee why good to see you
luckily we're playing indoors Oh Darius
Leonard calm down you're a little crazy
stop being a maniac but I think that the
Texans are I think both teams are gonna
be firing and I think this is gonna be I
think this could end up being the most
entertaining one o'clock game of the
week because I think that the Texans
haven't seen an offense like this in
weeks yeah and the Colts have been like
we let that game slip away I think I
think the Colts are gonna come out this
is gonna be one of their games of the
year right but I think they're gonna
keep it closer than five yeah I hear you
I the one thing that your last point is
what scares me the most is the fact that
when I thought about the Texans I said
man okay they have to stream elegance
they haven't played with a they haven't
played a like a what I'm experienced
really good quarterback yeah I like
Baker Mayfield
awesome last day but he'd made some
inexperienced type throws that ended and
the ground shot themselves the Foot so
much and you know what Josh looked at me
after the game right and the Texas ended
up winning that game they scored like
what 20-something points yeah yeah but
they had 27 points at halftime yeah I'm
worried about the Texans because they
let teams hang around sometimes and you
can't let luck hang around no you can
not
all right guys next game at one o'clock
here the Atlanta Falcons on the road
visiting the Green Bay Packers spread in
this game is Green Bay minus five and a
half whether in Green Bay on Sunday it
will be sunny with a high of 24 low of
13 whoa we are getting cold fellow that
is cold it is winter I've been there for
that type of temperature okay now the
Atlanta Falcons I guess the thing I
would say here is you know they've lost
to the Browns the Cowboys the Saints in
the Ravens four weeks in a row right the
one common theme with all four of those
losses is bludgeonings they've been
bludgeoned and all four where they've
just gotten you're the small little fast
Atlanta Falcons and we're just gonna
smash you and you're gonna go backwards
and we're gonna go forwards and you're
gonna lose cuz oh you're fast and you
play inside of the dome oh great well
the reading Bay Packers can to take
advantage of that they're not bludgeon
or not they're not budgeters that's now
I don't know what the Packers are no no
they're caught it's called save us Aaron
that's what that's what it is it's
called save us right so that's that's
where I look at that
it's weird week in Green Bay certainly I
like the Green Bay defense you know that
I like the creativity and things they do
but still I were I think Elena can be
able to run the ball on Green Bay a
little this is the type of team I think
they can run on and this is a type of
team that I get a little scared with
Green Bay's defense because other you
know they like to play a little
man-to-man a little too much and I just
think this is the wrong team that dance
around and that subject a little too
long so because of that I'm going $50 on
the Atlanta Falcons and I'm actually
picking the Atlanta Falcons to win this
football game which is crazy in
30-degree weather 24 to 23 I don't know
that's why I don't know I don't know
so the Falcons played in Green Bay in
week 14 in the years 2013 and the years
14 they lost both of those games close
by six points by one point so this time
of the year in two separate seasons in
2014 the last time Matt Ryan played
there he threw for 375 yards four
touchdowns and one interception this is
pre Kyle Shannon or is it beginning of
comes at 2014 they went to no that's not
there he's not there yet the Atlanta
offense on the road this season not
including the Washington yeah right that
was their outlier 12 17 16 17 Jays
that's that's disgusting Green Bay Aaron
Rodgers just faced in the last three
games
Arizona Minnesota Seattle good defensive
coaches pretty good athletes on the on
the defensive side of the ball and now
he's facing Atlanta I have the Packers
winning this game 27 to 22 which is only
five not five and a half so I'm putting
$50 on Atlanta to cover this spread
Julio Jones has played one game in Green
Bay hmm 11 catches 257 yards oh that's
right a touchdown jeez it was incredible
to watch I have one left go PR for Aaron
Rodgers that I'd really like him to do
wait until there's a crucial time of the
game and Joe Philbin is sitting there
looking like beaker from Sesame Street I
think that Aaron Rodgers should get down
on his knee and diagram a play in the
dirt even if it's not real get down at a
crucial time in the game get some people
around make sure there's an opening
where the cameras can see and just start
using your finger to diagram plays and I
think easy to use this chest like it's
right back here yeah like like face here
you're gonna go run here because I think
the visual
right would summarize this perfectly
because what Aaron Rodgers is trying to
prove right now is not that he's in
charge of the offense it's that in no
way is Joe Philbin allowed to be the
replacement for Mike McCarthy on this
team you mean the guy that called hasn't
called a offensive play call since 1996
if Joe Philbin right is legitimately a
candidate for the Green Bay Packers then
Mark Murphy needs to be fired
immediately like immediately because
that's why I think Aaron Rodgers needs
to get down and go you run here and you
run here and that image needs to go on
all social medias Aaron has to do
everything that's what my PR move would
be for him all right guys last game at
1:00 o'clock here the Carolina Panthers
all visiting the Cleveland Browns spread
in this game is Cleveland
sorry Carolina - to rusty negative loss
and Joe Philbin is like I haven't called
a play in like a decade and a half I'd
be like why did I hire you in Miami for
what reason
because you're not a diplomat and you're
not a good statesman I don't know Steven
Ross you're a good businessman do your
research that's what I gotta say to him
so it's his fault Carolina's a clear
line at Cleveland okay here we care
aligned a favor by - yeah
okay hey the Carolina Panthers offense
is good okay I don't know what else to
say they moved the ball on all of these
losses I mean other than the Pittsburgh
game I understand that was bad but the
Lions game moved the ball Seattle
Seahawks I mean never were stopped Tampa
Bay last week you know very few stops
they've really just been stopping
themselves that's really all it comes
down to can they limit the one or two
bad turnovers or not missed a field goal
or convert the fourth and inches those
are the type of situations that have
lost the Carolina Panthers games as of
late okay and to that point the
Cleveland Browns since Greg Williams has
taken over it's been pretty good it
really has their defense has improved
under his watch there is no doubt about
that
now on the other side of the ball the
Carolina Panthers do some good things on
defense always have their biggest issue
is just big plays that's really what it
comes down to they let up too many big
plays in big moments whenever it may be
and man can
Browns make some big plays they can
whether it's Nick Chubb rip it off 90
yard runs or Baker throwing bombs the
Callaway they're looking for the big
chunk place I'm not Landry oh well that
doesn't happen never mind yeah it
doesn't happen as much no doubt about it
yeah yeah but so I look at that and
that's what scares me I'm going with the
Carolina Panthers here okay I'm betting
$50 on Carolina I don't feel really good
about that there's aspects of the
Carolina Panthers that scare me the ones
I just mentioned specifically but I do
think they're going to win the game 24
to 20 just because they are still
playing for something and I think that
desperation will give them just enough
down the stretch to pull a close one out
against the Cleveland Browns so bill
Barnwell had an article about the teams
that just collapsed at this point of the
year the teams that had a chance the
Atlanta's the Carolinas that were in the
playoff race and then just evaporated
Carolina started off six and two and
then they went Owen four in there six
and two their offense was ranked ninth
their defense was ranked 16th and their
special teams are ranked third in the
last four games their offense is ranked
15th slight drop off their defense has
been 30 seconds and their special teams
has been 30 so that's good to know
Bradbury and Dante Jackson who's been
hurt a little too a little bit banged up
but they're getting zero pressure Julius
Peppers seemingly coming to the end yeah
the interior push is just not there
anymore
and the safety play hasn't been good and
also like they've lost a few games
because Graham Cano can't make kicks
missed a huge kick against Seattle they
come down and win the game
missed all of those kicks against
Detroit lost faith in them lost that
game they could be two and two if Graham
konoka kick kick yeah but in terms of
this game
Carolina's one in five on the road this
year straight up Browns are three now
against the spread against the NFC South
I know you love that one but I have the
Panthers winning 27 to 26
that's a Cleveland cover yeah I am
putting $100 on the Cleveland cover
and that is a $150 sweet Baker Mayfield
holding a dog say welcome to my crib
all right guys moving on to the four
o'clock games at 405 the Denver Broncos
on the road get his ass whooped by a
panther you better back the eff off the
Denver Broncos on the road visiting the
San Francisco 49ers spread in this game
is Denver - four and a half whether in
Santa Clara on Sunday high of 62 partly
cloudy very curious to see where you go
in this game well I usually screw this
game up that's the game including the
49ers and the leaden with your heart
with Kyle Shannon it obviously is
affecting me yes I'm giving him more
credit than he deserves in some games
and then the games he wins I seem to
always screw those up and pick those the
ones to be closer for some reason okay
um where do I want to start here okay
the San Francisco offense yes we know
they're able to run the ball just about
on anybody we know that I think the big
thing is though with that run game and I
do think Kyle's gonna find some flaws
within this Vance Joseph Joe woods run
defense but the Denver run defense has
gotten better ever since they were he
really has yeah ever since right it's
it's certainly they have corrected some
of those things ask some of their
players to stop doing some of the
unrealistic things they do do of course
I think this Broncos defense is pretty
damn good
there's no Chris Harris jr. that does
hurt them a little bit especially in a
game like this where you know there are
gonna be a few snaps we're gonna go man
we want to play man and we want to put
extra guys in the box to stop them run I
go to the other side of the ball and the
Broncos can run the ball you know that's
one thing they do have going for them
Phillip Lindsey you know Phillip Lindsey
but their number one pass target is gone
the big thing is case Kingdom's been
protecting the ball Nick Mullens has not
been protecting the ball okay the Denver
Broncos are still in the thick of things
even though though they are missing what
I would say is their second best player
on defense Chris Harris and either 1a or
1b best player on their offense
Timofey Lindsay right so Tarek wolf
might be out too so that that hurts me I
just think there's some things here that
scare me in the matchup altogether
I am betting $10 on the San Francisco
49ers Niners we will rock but I'm going
Broncos 2117 to win the game I am going
Niners winning the game whoa 24 to 21
Wow I am putting $50 on San Francisco
whoa
they gotta get a win and I I think I
when I watch the Denver Broncos offense
yeah it's Philip Lindsay it's Emmanuel
Sanders deep and it's Courtland Sutton
deep Emmanuel Sanders though was
everything yeah he's there an option
he's their number one slant he's their
number one in he's their number one out
he's their number one go he's the number
one screen he's the number one jet sweep
and he's out Chris Harris is out a bunch
of the D lineman are out the offensive
line even though they've been completely
banged up and they're both guards have
been out pretty much the whole year have
still been able to go I just think that
this is them gonna go I just think that
the the Kyle Shanahan running game will
have some success and I think that Case
Keenum is gonna try and force things
because at manual Sanders isn't there
right and I think what you said about
him protecting the ball we're gonna see
him not protected as much because he
thinks he has to do more my hope for
Denver is they go we need to build this
entire game plan now around Phillip
Lindsey we need to find a way to split
him out on the outside make him a
receiver sometimes he is so versatile
they got to find a way I know it sounds
crazy to even get on the ball more yeah
but I don't think they're gonna be able
to do it right wet the right away I
think San Francisco actually wins this
game okay I can't pick San Francisco to
win a game at all right now do it
I don't trust Nick Mullens or some of
the guys too well doesn't always seem to
have bad turnovers you know even last
week they're driving the ball down there
the game is in the balance the kid
Wilson fumbles when there unlike the 10
yard line it always seems to be
something like that scared I have more
faith since they're at home that those
turnovers aren't gonna happen but I tote
like its Niners yes
all right guys next game at 4 o'clock
here the Cincinnati
bangles on the road visiting the Los
Angeles chargers spread in this game is
Chargers -14 and weather in LA on Sunday
71 partly cloudy okay um hey the
Chargers miss Melvin Gordon there's no
doubt about that
you know Austin hecklers good and all
that but damn he's small and he's just
not gonna get the tough yards the memory
Gordon team already came out and said
that he's starting to wear down they're
gonna incorporate two of their running
back yeah the kid Jackson was more
impressive in the game at the end of the
you forget Austin hecklers their number
one special teams guide right right so
he's playing like a lot of snaps snaps
so to do that that running or that sighs
now you're trying to run between the
tackles you're taking a beating during
the week and he's probably not even
feeling normal until like Friday
afternoon so okay but but at the very
least the Bengals defense sucks we all
know that it's horrible they can't stop
crap they're not gonna stop this team I
know that I would think the Chargers
march up and down the field on them at
will now going to the other side I don't
know I mean of course I don't have faith
in the Bengals offense and I didn't
watch the film from the Bengals last
week either yet Jeff Driskel though just
to my eye
keeping tv-watching didn't look out of
place I also saw some running game with
Joe Mixon and you know I don't think the
Chargers defense is special I thought
they had a chance to kind of get it
together I think they are what they are
at this point they're small they can
make some plays here and there but you
can drive the ball on them I am going
with the charges to win this game of
course and I'm betting $100 on the
Chargers I don't give a damn if it's the
14-point spread
I think they're gonna I'm going only a
hundred though cuz I just worry about
some of the playmakers and the Bengals
or maybe the Chargers just sleeping
after a East Coast trip on a Sunday
night big game so that's where I'm
checking out I'm picking the charge to
win 38 20 and you're going hard I mean
relatively I'm putting a hundred and
fifty dollars on the Chargers I have
them winning 31 to 14
this is the biggest mismatch of the week
I think the Bengals did just stick
there's a part of me that wishes this
game was in Cincinnati because I feel
like the Chargers play better on the
road then when they go home but the good
thing is is there's not going to be this
will be the first time all year where I
feel like the Chargers are gonna have a
home-field advantage
yeah I don't think any Bengals Knights
are making the trip now and even if they
are they're gonna be like don't beat us
bite too much yeah I think the Bengals
stink man like this is how much you bet
150 okay but but you didn't want to go
hard no I kind of kept it I'm keeping it
even pretty much everywhere yeah but
this is one of mine 150 is a big bet for
me yeah for like how I been right all
right guys next game at 425 on Sunday
the Detroit Lions on the road visiting
the Arizona Cardinals spreading this
game Chris is Detroit - two and a half
when I went through all my games
I wrote down under this one yeah I ain't
betting [ __ ] on this game I hear you
I'm betting ten dollars on the Lions
2320 I don't I think both I think that
that bad ass [ __ ] lion coming
down there to Arizona Cardinal world no
I don't know I just think that I'm going
with I don't know either of these teams
you know don't really know either
I'm the tennis I trust both defensive
coordinators there's a good defensive
game plans to stop somewhat of these
simple offenses that lack explosive
weapons so I look at that and that's
where I think it could be an ugly
football game at the end of the day I'm
just going with Matt Stafford
they're running attack a little bit and
just gonna go with that I don't know
what else I can really am I scared that
Chandler Jones gets around the edge and
strips acts of Matthew Stafford once or
twice certainly a.m. but I'm just going
with the team that's got a little more
experience at the quarterback position
in some other positions and I'm going
Lions winning the game 23 20 hi the
Lions winning 17 to 16 I am putting $50
on the Arizona
Cardinals $50 $60 rings I'm writing down
all the swings right now but Arizona
it's I'll take that in a game of two
teams that I find to be somewhat evenly
matched easily confusing I'm gonna take
the home dog of two and a half yeah yeah
I hear that I was fast yeah that game
like like if you're betting on that game
yeah I need you to call a hotline you're
a degenerate I think that's the thing
that's the thing that people forget
about this show is that not everyone
bets on every game that would be a
source to me that would be a stupid
thing to do we just do it because it's
entertaining right okay next game on
Sunday at 425 the Pittsburgh Steelers
visiting the Oakland Raiders we could do
a show like that where we just pick the
games we would actually like we could
talk about the other games but we just
don't even waste our money on the crap
games and we just go these are the three
I think it's more fun to bet on every
day all right spread in this game is
Pittsburgh minus ten and a half whether
in Oakland on Sunday is partly cloudy
high of 59 you do tell people the games
that you're more confident in yes I hope
my money explains that to be more than
anything you're betting $10 on the lines
yes exactly right that means don't bet
anything it means I have to bet $10
because it's a show so that's why who
the hell are we doing it's Berg at
Oakland Pittsburgh minus ten and a half
okay so largest spread of the weekend is
this the largest one okay so the thing I
would look at here it's not larger than
the Chargers game
oh you were correct yes I think okay the
Raiders defense
I mean plays hard it really does I'm not
gonna sit there and ever complain about
their effort and I don't really have
sometimes complain about their game plan
I mean their game plans are correct in a
lot of ways they're under man they're
forced into a corner sometimes yes
exactly right
that's just the wrong week to be
undermanned and not talented against
really an offense that's kind of you
know close to unstoppable force really
the only way that they get stopped as of
late is when they just stop themselves
whether it's you know guys fumbling on
the one-inch line or big been missing a
wide open pass or you know rpoS when we
don't do them
all game long and we decided to do with
him the biggest play of the game at the
one-yard line whatever it may be that's
what's been stopping the Pittsburgh
Steelers now so I expect Pittsburgh to
be able to move the ball any way they
seem deemed necessary and this one and I
hope we see a little more Jalen Samuel
at the running back which it sounds like
we're going to which is I'm a very
excited he's definitely out okay I
wasn't even sure I knew we had the ankle
issue I wasn't sure how long he was out
I'm excited for that I don't think it's
gonna be any drop off there at all I'm a
Jalen samuel fan maybe i'm wrong
everybody can tell me what an [ __ ] I
am if I am wrong next week so they move
the ball other side of the ball I have
no faith on the Oakland offense to move
the ball consistently on the Pittsburgh
Steelers defense Pittsburgh it's
creative they can beat you but they can
rush you with four yes they're not like
the man demand team that you know we'd
like them to be but I think they're
gonna be able to get away with man to
man on the snaps they need to against
this bunch in Oakland there's nobody
there that I'm gonna go oh no if they
play five snaps Amanda man against Jordy
Nelson in company whoa they're screwed I
think Pittsburgh of course is going to
be pissed off I think Pittsburgh knows
that they have to right the ship I just
look at this as all the things going
damn we got New England next week and I
don't look at that New England thing on
their schedule next week as being a bad
thing in this case because they've just
had two bad losses I think they're gonna
come into this game with urgency going
[ __ ] we gotta play good this week and go
into the New England game with good
vibes $360 on the Pittsburgh Steelers
BAM Pittsburgh and I think Pittsburgh is
going to win this game 35 to 17 I'm
gonna put my money first and then I'm
gonna explain it I'm putting a hundred
and fifty dollars on the Oakland Raiders
oh I love it so that is a five hundred
and ten dollar swing zim since 2003 the
Steelers and have played on the west
coast ten times they're two and eight Oh
new since Big Ben has taken over a
quarterback right they've played the
Raiders three times
they've been favourites three times
they've lost three times numbers are
favoring me here in what way these means
the outliers coming interesting yeah
last time it happened they were a nine
point favorite I love that the Patriots
came as next week I love that they're
sitting thinking about the past and the
future at the same time I think there's
more fear in their mind right now
great what's gonna be really awesome is
when the Oakland Raiders focus on Jared
Cook against Bostick and you're gonna
sit there and go damn it I knew that was
the weakness and the Raiders were able
to target because if you're seeing it
your Godfather Jon Gruden is deaf I know
what the Steelers have seen and I've
already told you that he only played
about ten plays last week that's fine
that's different personnel for the
Raiders and the Chargers simply Austin
Eckler being out there scared them
I think the Raiders offense has been
pretty good as of late and I think that
I think that ten and a half points is
too much I really do for a Steelers
defense that I think is kind of all over
the place sometimes yeah so I think
they're gonna be looking past it and
looking behind it and I really like the
ten and a half mmm man that's a big one
I disagree with you 500 how are you
gonna say like what is what is like all
over the place about the Pittsburgh
defense like what is all over the place
I mean it was it was good was it the 16
points against Jacksonville the 17
points against the Broncos you know the
23 points last week 23 that's perfect
for me to describe no it was well I mean
I guess you're not included upon return
so there that's not not the defense so
I've seen them fall apart in last week's
second half now I seen them to play
awful the entire game against Denver
I saw them play one good quarter against
Jacksonville and it's that them like
Carolina I feel like Kadena Carolina
played that game and then since then
neither team has been themselves right
and so it's in Oakland it says Oakland
Super Bowl Jon Gruden
probably showing clips from the 1970s
about the Steel Curtain and the Oakland
Raiders and I think this is it and I
also think the Steelers are looking
ahead it not just the Patriots but the
Saints the weekend after that they're
thinking about playoff seeding this is
it for the Raiders yeah and so for me if
this like I just watched the Raiders
kind of hang in there with the Chiefs I
note that Steelers defense is a lot
better than the Chiefs you're getting
more confidence I'm talking I yes I am I
am I feel really I feel good about this
I do I do
I mean I'm you're picking a dumpster
fire and I'm picking a team that's lost
two games where they whoop the [ __ ] out
of two teams and lost that's all that's
all I'm saying mmm yeah all right guys I
don't feel that good next game at 425
the feeling I feel the same feeling I
feel last week when you tried to tell me
Atlanta was gonna be Baltimore that's
how I feel so that's bodes well for me
really yeah baby bites his bottom lip
there [ __ ] well I'm going I don't know I
don't know don't let me pressure you I
don't know
come on you're beating me next game for
twenty five hundred and ten dollars
swing that's the whole thing we got we
got us we got a few swings this week got
a few we're swinging baby was swinging
baby I love that commercial by the way
what's commercial you haven't seen that
commercial of it like do you sling no
there you know who's the Austin Powers
no sling like there's a sling box right
and the funny comedian and the girl from
Will and Grace the redheaded girl that's
I guess they do like where they go at
dinner and they're like we're slinging
baby and they talk to other couples and
they think they're saying swinging right
that's really funny you guys ready okay
all right next game at 4:25 the
Philadelphia Eagles on the road visiting
the Dallas Cowboys spread in this game
is Dallas - three and a half take it
away
that has now become the most interesting
four o'clock game yes oh man okay hold
I'm flustered I'm getting stuff up here
okay so here Tomlin only cares about the
big games he's overlooking this one so
much all right so here we go
Philadelphia's offense versus the Dallas
defense I don't like that matchup you
know I don't I don't think you like it
how can you what's there to like so that
scares me I think there's a lot of
pressure on Carson Wentz excuse me -
just make magic happen overall I do
think the Dallas defense is kind of
rolling right now they're feeling
themselves I do believe they're a team
of momentum you know they're the bigger
faster stronger team they were the year
that they made that run that's what they
are they're I don't think they're the
team that like let's down I think
there's a team that starts to go like
it's like every wins like here's an
extra pump of steroids into our brain
our muscles oh we're better this week
like I think that's the kind of team
they are third bullies and when they
when they're feeling like we're bullying
people
they thrive and that kind of you know
environment now you know so I expect
your defense to really or the their
defense to give your Eagles off that's a
very tough time and I make sure you do
as well I guess the other side of the
ball you know again I don't think Dallas
is just gonna run rough shop over this
Philadelphia defense in the run game but
I do worry just the Dallas has found
just enough of a pass game to scare you
and I'm Ari Cooper is scary right now I
mean he is and dak Prescott is throwing
the ball the last few weeks about as
good as I've ever seen him cuz Amari
Cooper worth that first round pick yes
yeah it just it goes into our thing any
of you heard some of his comments lately
I meant to talk about this no he's
really opened up and admitted that he
did not enjoy football and that he's got
to start approaching it different and
his attitude he think was like it was
gray actually I've been to bring this up
the last two podcasts where it was very
like again like self-fulfilling for me
to hear that because we always thought
he that was his biggest issue right that
is like it's hard to get a read he's no
charisma and guys like Jon Gruden or
like hey I'm trying to feed you the ball
and you haven't even showed me a facial
expression in seven weeks so now he's on
the team that's going just be you yeah
catch the ball make deadly I think he
realized I think it was like an epiphany
where he's like wait I'm playing
football and I'm a receiver and I'm
awesome like what am I so
angry or like I saw a picture of him
coming out of an i8 BMW in like a full
velour suit with a nice smile that's
those are the things I'm talking about
was like I haven't seen him in like that
in 3 years he's been opening up about it
a little bit how he's had to change his
outlook so yes is what I'm saying and I
just think that when you say to your
secondary and the things are going
Dallas rolling I think Dallas wins this
game I'm betting $100 on the Dallas
Cowboys and I'm picking them to win a
close 27 to 17 game and when I mean that
I mean like I think it's gonna be 20 to
17 and Dallas gets like a you know four
minutes left in the game touchdown to
put it over the edge to make it 27 to 17
and closes it out I picked the Cowboys
to win the NFC East and picking them to
win this game twenty three to twenty one
that is an Eagles cover I am putting $50
on it I think that this is every last
ounce of eagles yeah every last ounce
yeah the thing that excited me the most
last week as an Eagles fan the REIT I
don't want to hear the song the
re-emergence of the screen yeah I didn't
know where it went
right it's adorable seeing Darren
Sproles out there every time he gets hit
I'm praying for his life
it's this spread comes down to will
there be an Amari Cooper run after catch
that he's just faster than everybody and
it's very possible right but I think
that this is going to be the best Eagles
defensive performance of the season and
I think that Carson's gonna have to make
magic and I've seen him make magic in
Dallas before because golden Tate's
gonna have to be crafty Alshon Jeffery
and Earth's are gonna have to win those
one-on-one matchups against very
talented defenders I still have the
Cowboys winning I just think it's gonna
be close and I'm not betting on the
Cowboys it's just as an Eagles fan I'm
gonna throw my money down the dumpster
instead of betting on the Cowboys I mean
I don't think it's that crazy I mean
it's not like you're living
crazy villains yeah one I think is like
I said I think it's I picked the 2717
close 10 point win like where it's three
points alright and like my hope is that
they don't get that 17 exactly right I
see that's why I couldn't bet on this
game like anything extravagant cuz they
just who knows which way that goes
alright guys let's move on to Senate
Night Football the Los Angeles Rams on
the road visiting the Chicago Bears
spread in this game is Rams -3 weather
in Chicago on Sunday low of 25
clear skies Chris what's the wind chill
wind chill I will have to pull that up I
don't have windchill but that's that's
the first thing I think of in this game
only thing about the game
that makes me go Chicago right there's
not a I before I thought about the
weather yeah this was gonna be my big
bed of the week this is gonna be your
big bet and then I thought about the
weather right I thought about Jared Goff
tiny hands yeah and I got scared yeah I
mean the weather's the first thing I
thought of him is the first thing that I
looked up actually when I heard the game
I just said it snowed in Denver yeah ran
it for 200 yards exactly what are you
doing that against Chicago exactly right
so first thing I would say is I think
this Bears defense really matches up
well with the Rams I mean really yeah
scheme wise everything how does the
scheme match up well with your ski there
are very good at zones and things of
putting people in the middle of the
field they can play man when they have
to they're not gonna have to blitz or do
anything to compromise that in the back
end with their front four they're not
gonna have to run blitz or do anything
like that to disrupt all of that you
know up front and that matchup yeah I
think the Bears are better than the Rams
up front interesting you know the skill
guys against the Rams offense the Bears
defense yeah I might give the Rams the
advantage but I don't think it's my a
lot not on things not with that safety
duo and fuller out there who really good
sign of sideline but exactly right the
guy the linebackers on the edge as well
and you got a count Khalil and Floyd and
that mix a little bit like athis Pass
Road yeah right I know so they're kind
of like hybrids but either way you got
the point and I do I think Fangio III
I'm a big fan of Vic Fangio you know
that and what he does now I flip it to
the other side I actually think this is
a pretty good matchup for the Bears
offense I really do for these reasons
you've heard me talk about the
aggressive nation stop looking at my
sheet to see when I'm betting over there
used you seen the he's already death
you've seen that and you've heard me say
the Rams I mean you know it they let up
too many big plays at times that's all
there is to it there's too many big
plays they go for the kill they would be
a better defense if they just played
more simple close to the vest they have
the talent to do that and so now we have
that defense and it's a pretty good ol
line and an offense that can do a little
bit of everything and a good play game
plan designer okay and Mitchell sure
brisk ease back which thank God okay I
hope the Bears fans embrace him now I
think they they should they should give
him a standing O when he's back in I
mean chase Daniels tried to screw the
game up in Detroit and damn he did screw
it up last week I'm bidding $50 on the
Chicago Bears and I'm picking the Bears
to win the game really I am I'm picking
them to win a 31-28 type of football
game I think they can muster up now I've
only betting $50 so as competent as I
sound in those things [ __ ] this is a
huge week so the the the I'm Bowie
betting $50 though because I can also
see this game being tied and Aaron
Donnell getting a strip sack fumble time
or an explosive pass play from Iran I'm
betting on I think about these two teams
in the way that they play their pace of
game yeah I feel like Chicago always
starts off at home jumping out to like a
10 nothing lead and I feel like every
time I watch the Rams in the second half
they roar back like a freight train on
the game sure and I'm thinking that
Aaron Donald and in Douma can sue can
disrupt the entire nature of this
offense now I get very concerned about
Tariq Cowan on the linebackers of the
rams because I think they're a huge
liability but I'm also not afraid of a
single wide receiver on this Chicago
Bears team yeah and I'm still worried
about Mitchell job risky outside just as
much as I am on Jared Goff but I do like
that mr. Trobe risky can run yeah this
game was in LA
Rams kill him but all your points are
valid I'm betting $100 on the Rams I had
them winning 27 to 20 yeah it's tough
one this is it's like the Ravens I'm
going out on a limb and picking the team
that you not supposed to win but I do
you want something a football this
weekend I am yeah
so you're how many other people do you
think are gonna pick the Bears oh I
don't know defeat it I know I lost last
week who'd you pick the Steelers oh yeah
let's stink house a heartbreaker but uh
it's just one of those games where the
moment in the year if the Rams whether
if the Rams lose man the Saints can just
clinch well if they got to beat the Bucs
yeah I know it's gonna be tough the
Bears are a scary playoff team they're
scary
you're not gonna be uncomfortable with
the Bears coming into town cuz you're
gonna go damn there's talent they got a
few playmakers on offense and damn their
defense well I also want to say this too
what you're saying yeah if somehow the
Saints lose to the Bucs
which we've said is not crazy right and
they beat the Rams right all of a sudden
all they all the Bears need is one more
Saints loss right and if they can
somehow get home-field advantage
that's the only chance that the Bears
have like we said last year the only
chance that the Eagles have of going to
the Super Bowl is being able to play in
the elements right because it wouldn't
get the offenses of the Rams the Falcons
the Saints all those together right the
only chance the Bears have because if
the Bears play in a dome doesn't matter
problem right the band the Bears go out
to LA it's not really gonna matter yeah
but if it's cold windy Chicago on grass
Jared Goff and Drew Brees are in trouble
yeah I hear you but man I'm kind of
rooting for you now Thanks in that game
connect game because chaos and the NFC
might be pretty us it would be cool all
right guys last game of the week is
Monday Night Football the Minnesota
Vikings on the road visiting the Seattle
seams Sunday night Monday night spread
in this game is Seattle - three and a
half whether in Seattle on Monday night
is thunderstorms with a high of 39 this
storms with a high of 39 that's like
weird is it that's called climate change
I'm not the weatherman I just read the
report here you guys want me to go to
the global warming nothing
good and says this is the battle for are
you facing the NFC East winner or are
you facing the Bears because this is
really the battle for the five or six
seed and I'd well I don't know who I'd
rather play if the Cowboys keep being
hot but let's see yeah you're right so
let's late what I'd rather play the
Cowboys in the Bears yeah I would too
maybe that's close though
this isn't it yeah if you have to go
down to Dallas and play that D I mean
that's gonna be a struggle - you're
right that's a tough one all right all
right Minnesota and Seattle both lost in
Chicago so they'd probably rather play
in Dallas yes right Minnesota offense
Seattle defense
okay Seattle defense is solid it's not
great ittsan certainly not like the
Seattle defenses we've seen in years
past I get that but the Minnesota
Vikings I I just don't have faith in the
offense until I see a run game just so
you know yeah I've listened to a lot of
different podcasts and I just wanted to
hear other people's space yeah you're
not alone on your D Philip OH doubting
okay good there's a lot of people in the
space right now that are going I don't
know what the offense is remember Mike
Zimmer has come out a few times ago and
can we run the ball more right and when
you play the Patriots and it's 10:10 and
Dalvin cook touches the ball less than
ten times in the second half that was a
nationally televised game that has a lot
of people wondering what you've been
wondering in the whole city yeah I just
I think we're rushing to judgment a
little again I will defend John Doe D
filippo and say that I do think he's
head coach material in the future I just
don't think his offense is quite where
it needs to be yet before you hire him
as a head coach to be the offensive guru
quarterback Whisperer or guy he's not
there yet
so yeah - what everything we talked
about just scares me
you know the Seattle Seahawks - they're
a team that's really pride themselves on
not letting up big plays the cover three
press bail is all about keeping you not
allowing you to go deep behind them and
keep them underneath I think they're of
course gonna be very aware of that fact
I mean the numbers I'm sure bear out
that that's the type of team the
Minnesota Vikings are and yeah when
you're that much of a one-trick pony
against the Seattle Seahawks that scares
me up in Seattle Seattle you can run the
ball on Seattle but
just don't have the faith that you know
the guys up front for a Minnesota can
get it done and that the coach would
stay consistent with it the other side
of the ball
Minnesota their defense I do think they
match up pretty well with the Seattle
Seahawks I really do
Seattle's run game though is still
pretty damn good and all the things they
do and the three-headed monster at
running back and there are big plays in
the pass game that's what they are too
and they rely on the big play in the
pass game too much but the difference is
between them and Minnesota is that they
have a run game to go with it so those
big plays present themselves a little
bit more on a weekly basis than in
Minnesota where like last week and never
presented itself because the Patriots
were like we're not gonna let you get
the big play in the past game we don't
think you can run it so we're gonna play
safe on the back end and I think Seattle
will follow that same mantra I am going
$100 on the Seattle Seahawks
I think the Seattle Seahawks win this
game 28 to 20 and that's that the
Seahawks taken it to be 28 dude I feel
the same way I'm picking the Seahawks to
win 27:17 right and I'm putting a
hundred dollars on the Seattle's too so
that's a wash everything you said is how
I feel so I don't need to go into it I
think also Seattle at home it's a
special place now Kirk Cousins went into
Seattle last year with Washington and
won 1714 really well yeah Russell Wilson
has never lost to the Vikings he's
through you know the only time he's
faced Zimmer with the Vikings Seattle
won 38 to 7 and he threw for 274 and
three touchdowns in the regular season
game in Minnesota but they also went up
there and played them in the playoffs in
that really cold game it didn't have as
great a day right I remember where they
missed the field at the end in the
spirit of our show yeah I have a prime
time stat for you baby
Pete Carroll took over the Seahawks and
2010 Sims and they've played 17 prime
time
and in those games they've gone 15 and -
oh you know prime time games lost one of
them this year to the Chicago Bears
right right but still like that is
really impressive to be that good on a
national stage it is like really good
and then when you turn it around and
there's teams like Washington that it
never wins on prime-time yeah it is
interesting
it is it's because he's a gamer he got
guys on the same way about toppers right
there a little too much into that at
times but yes that's you know that they
thrive in that and then they get players
on their team that I feel like they love
them Friday media meeting right I feel
like they love doing like the sit-down
interviews on Saturday for their little
spotlights I watched a little bit NFL
Network the other day they mentioned
prime time like 17 times in 20 minutes
it's so annoying how do you think he's
gonna handle prime time I don't know why
don't we talk about Khalil Mack instead
of whether or not the lights are on at
Soldier Field to think that that
actually affects players like I just I
don't just it's so it's just it is funny
though that after the game Philip Rivers
goes it's actually nice to talk to you
Michele Tafoya I haven't seen you
because we're never on prime time right
so this is great right it was kind of
fun yeah
this has to be the most we've ever
disagreed this season I can I can tally
it up and I haven't tallied up I haven't
all tallied up I'm doing the whole show
it scares me because I did all my picks
last night I spent zero time on it today
very scared your back porch in it too
while you're doing it so yeah you're all
over I did rain the scrambling back
porch was under construction I didn't
have any material to rebuild the port oh
damn nine and seven eight nine
agreements seven disagreements a $60
disagreement you have Jacksonville I
have Tennessee a 250 dollar disagreement
you have houston i of indy a hundred and
fifty dollar disagreement you have
carolina
I have Cleveland a sixty dollar
disagreement you have Detroit I of
Arizona a hundred and fifty dollar
disagreement you have Dallas I have
Philly a 150 dollar disagreement you
have Chicago I
the Rams and a five hundred and ten
dollar disagreement uf Pittsburgh
I have Oakland who are you locking I
have four home teams you have three home
teams in the disagreements there is
thirteen hundred and thirty dollars up
for grabs in those seven disagreements
but really I have all my freakin eggs in
the Oakland Raiders it's good what the
[ __ ] am I think I don't know I don't
know well you know what I'm thinking
it's not prime time where I'm leaning in
terms of locks right I am nervous but I
am leaning towards New England yeah
because I know it's Miami it just it
just feels like the New England seems
gonna be different I'm thinking about
lock in Baltimore plus six and a half I
really AM okay I'm mad at you for that
oh that's crazy at all when it comes to
the other games dude I don't know if I
want to lock Tampa Bay also but I'm
thinking about it Wow
locking tapes and the Saints that's what
I'm saying it's a little scary but Tampa
Bay plus eight the thing that's scaring
me yeah is you saying if it does rain it
helps out in New Orleans I do I think
they're the the muck it up team I'm
thinking about lock and buffalo yeah you
like that one I as we've sat here and
I'm thinking I'm singing my grantee to
lose as we're doing this I keep going
back to that game I'm going there's no
way the Jets can be that's how I feel
yeah that's just one we're like the
thing that sucks about locking a Tampa
and the thing that sucks about locking
and Oakland is that I don't feel like
I'm gonna be in the driver's seat for
most of that game right and I'm relying
hoping the hole back there but Baltimore
I feel like I am gonna be in the driver
seat yeah and it's gonna be I hate
rooting against mahomes but it's okay
in terms of other locks I might go with
Chargers in the 14
I hate laying the wood with 14 I'm not
gonna lie to you when I was picking the
game and he
sitting next to me and I was going
through my numbers I was really scared
that I was going you were gonna just
kill me with the charger spangles game
cause you were like I want to bet it but
there was just something holding me back
and I was like man everything in my mind
tells me to bet a little more there so
right I just if you need my verification
my only question would be is do I go
Seattle because that's the only other
one that I feel pretty good about it's a
simpler offense against the Seattle team
that has Russell Wilson because if I go
Seattle then I could take maybe you know
what do you think
what are you deciding between there well
Seattle or Chargers hmm I think I do
Chargers Seattle or New England I know
we're used to in yeah I would go New
England Seattle or Baltimore I would go
to altom or Seattle or Buffalo I would
go Buffalo okay yeah so I think that my
locks are gonna be Buffalo at home New
England on the road Baltimore on the
road Chargers at home one dog three
favorites alright I think that's what
I'm doing
okay I'm a mess ah here's how we're
doing this yeah Nikki G came up to me
yeah told him we want surprise for
guaranteed to lose we were doing a
little bit of cryptic fortune teller we
did our goofy seat spinners last week
took it to the streets
yeah Sims little hip hop he came to me
today and he says I have an idea but I
think it'd be funnier if you don't know
I do not know Nikki G hit the music it's
time for guaranteed to lose
and here we go is a guaranteed to lose
Jamboree and for the first time since
guess we're going hey no Buffalo hold on
to your horses here okay
jets you're welcome to guaranteed to
lose there's no way you're going up to
Buffalo they circle them wagons better
than anybody and Sam Donald hasn't
played in a while and it's tough going
to play in Buffalo against that defense
sorry Jets you're gonna lose if there's
anyone that needs to say their Hail
Marys it's Seamus Winston man's lived a
triple lap and he's up against the side
oh gosh that's not a good thing the holy
Saints yes holy crap the Bucs are gonna
lose this one I can't pick you to beat
the Saints who are still one of the best
teams in football buck speed beds not
good they gonna lose the Saints yeah
Buck's gonna lose Mack your knees let's
go down to Bahama Mama okay but the
Dolphins they're gonna lose okay it's
the wigglin Tommy Boy and company are
mad at the Revolution whoa can't change
the stripes on a tiger a pound a nice
girl I got a hatter we went to LA and
now I got a play and Sims what do you
say gonna lose I'd never seen the bangle
in Cincinnati first of all I don't know
big is there but I don't think their
defense exists either and the charges
offense is awesome back I was gonna lose
last week Sims went for and won and
guaranteed Lou this week he's gonna have
a record with a similar broom next one
he's about to tell you won't go that
well that's right because this Raiders
pick is going straight to hell oh how
dare you that's to me yes Raiders you
shall lose you're usually the tough team
wearing black but there's a tougher team
coming into town this week the bet base
stealers excuse me have come off too bad
losses they know who's on the horizon
they got to get their game straight they
will whoop the Raiders Nick don't quit
that music keep playing it hey Josh how
you feeling sitting down over there I'm
feeling fantastic thanks for asking
you're welcome keep on talkin how much
is he gonna ha how much is he gonna cut
out of this
so I want to say one thing when Josh
comes in on us and we watch the games
together
Josh is in a confidence pool with his
brother where they pick three games
against the spread yeah we're not gonna
win this year though they allocate one
point two points or three points have
you guys talked yet we have not talked
we talked Friday afternoons after
listening to us what are you gonna say
to your brother about the games that man
he is because a lot of comments always
say and people that listen the homies
always say we love to listen you break
down the game so we don't necessarily
take your bets
all right so as someone that sits here
homie what interested you the most
honestly I'll probably stick with you
guys on Baltimore will probably make
that our three or our - mm-hmm beyond
that I couldn't tell you
know where my brother is very he's very
inconsistent he always looks at what the
public wants to do and then we go from
there what percentage of the time do you
leave this and go Sims is gonna kick
left goes ass this week I just generally
assume that as a usual rule yeah but I
would I feel pretty confident in Chris
this week so we're all gonna watch games
together and wildcard week and it sounds
like let's bet some real money that day
my question Josh would my question my
request for you is can you explain to
Sims what it's been like to watch games
me this year because this is the first
year that Sims has not watched games
with me it has been man I want to think
of the perfect adjective to describe
this I've had to just stop listening to
let go and just be like I'm no longer
listening to you talk so you can talk to
yourself because I'm not gonna respond
but I always just talk to myself anyway
constantly with the fantasy team he's
yelling at the TV he's angry that the
iPad isn't working someone is changing
the channels look at my fantasy team I
don't my life suck it's it's nonstop for
three hours yeah I always stay for the
early games because I can't take five
hours I leave it for a clock because I
can't I can't do it just like stand up
and pace around and watch all the games
and I know I've seen it he experienced
I've seen four years doesn't stop you
others as people in the room or not
I love cursing out people to have you
bring your boys this year and what about
your boy business your boy last year
that came
can't remember what cake I think it was
Jake Joe from State Farm Jake from State
Farm how to trap what I'm wearing Jake
yeah you're down disgusting
well it's Jake's a guy so yes all right
so thirteen hundred and thirty dollars I
feel like the game we should play with
the homies is we put up the seven
different bets and it's who do you think
he votes yeah who do you think wins
these games left oh that's good and I
would probably bet on Sims this week but
I don't know we're gonna find out we are
gonna fight for Sims good luck peace out
homies thank your fender ik good evening
everybody
and for the lef koe man good luck to you
too oh thank you how courteous we are
guys we appreciate you as always I hope
your team does well maybe there's chaos
this weekend we'll find out soon enough
you